hello there today we're looking at
language models are few shot learners by
Tom B brown Benjamin man Nick Ryder and
Melanie sabaha and a whole of authors
all slew of authors from OPI this paper
also called GPT three just came out
recently so GPT three is a model that is
a language model and it comes out of a
succession of language models of open e
I this paper is basically an
investigation into what you can do with
giant language models now this language
model is an order of magnitude larger
than anyone has ever built a language
model and it can do some absolutely
crazy things so we'll basically go over
the architecture over what the model
does and over the experimental results
it turns out that if you train a
language model on enough data it is able
to solve NLP tasks that it has never
seen just out of the box and we're gonna
look into this very cool kind of
formulation of the problem as you can
see here the paper is 40 pages long
without the appendix it needs its own
table of contents which is crazy so
we're going to skip a fair bit of things
so first of all what is a language model
for those of you don't know I've done a
bunch of videos and you can see those in
my natural language processing playlist
about language models and specifically
about transformer language models so a
language model let's just take an
example this sentence right here just
the sentence as such like third humans
do not require to do not require large
supervised data sets to learn most
language tasks right this is an English
sentence and a language model would be a
model that if you cross out a portion
from the end here like this right here
it would be able to tell you what comes
next so in a language model you would
input this part right here and it will
tell you the next word is data sets so
that's basically all the language model
does and once you've trained one you can
be
basically generate word after word after
word from it or you can ask it a
question like which word is most likely
to come next or more likely so a
language model is nothing but a model
that can kind of generate language in a
probabilistic way and the cool thing
about language models is that you can
train it on any sort of text data and
that's what they do here so they train a
language model on giant amounts of data
specifically right here they go into the
data sets they use they use this let's
skip down they use this common crawl
data set which they filter down for
quality and this is basically a crawl of
the entire Internet if you will together
with these books data sets and the web
text data set and the Wikipedia data set
so if they throw all of this text that
they scrape from the internet together
and then train a language model on that
now the the the the language model right
here is called GPT three and they train
various sizes of it and we'll get into
how it's built in a second but just
compare this to a language model like
Burt Burt required this much flops to
Train and these this is a log scale so
this is right here this is several
orders of magnitude larger and bigger
model and is trained for way longer on
this text so naturally it is going to be
a lot better at language modeling you
can see right here the size of these
models that they trained on remember the
previous largest language model the
Turing nlg of Microsoft had something
like 17 billion parameters so it would
be comparable to this right here whereas
GPT 3 has 175 billion parameters which
this is absolutely crazy is an order of
magnitude higher than anything that ever
existed and if you look at the last GPT
the GPT
to model that if you remember I've made
a video about it is too dangerous to be
released well now it has been released
but was too dangerous to be released it
clocked in at about 1.5 billion
parameters so compared to this GPT three
Excel model right here they trained
these multiple models to basically
estimate the effect of the model size
and you can see here the largest model
has ninety-six attention layers it each
layer has 96 attention heads and each
head is 128 dimensional and it trains on
batches of size 3.2 million this is the
batch size absolutely crazy so they
train this on a giant distributed
cluster that apparently is provided by
Microsoft and yes crazy crazy things so
how does this model look this model is a
transformer model and right here we
don't even have like a description of a
transformer model let's just assume you
know what that is I have made several
videos on transformer models and
especially things like attention is all
you need or Burt or something like this
but for those who don't know if I have a
transformer model and I want to build a
language model from it let's take this
sentence right here
I would input a what's called a context
which is the thing I already have right
I would input that into a transformer
model and a transformer model is just
several layers of attention mechanism
now an attention mechanism is basically
a way where information is routed in
between the different tokens right here
and as it goes up the layer basically
the the information is routed around and
the model can make various inferences
and at the end the model is supposed to
come up with the next word that you're
going to put here specifically in this
paper they use sub words like word piece
tokens like it is common in NLP right
now but essentially this is an auto
regressive language model so it's not
like Bert it's not by direction
it is autoregressive it goes from left
to right always produces the next word
it is like GPT - they even say this they
say we use the same model and
architecture as GPT - they just have
more layers and wider layers and more
data to train it on so how do they train
it
okaythat's we already said they train it
in simply in simply a language modeling
way just next word prediction that's it
okay it's so it's not even something
fancy like Bert the interesting part is
when you do the now the single tasks so
what you usually did with something like
Bert so with something like Bert you
would do first pre train so there you
would this is the language modeling
right here this pre training phase where
you teach Bert about the English
language by just feeding it a lot of
data and then second you had a step
called fine tuning fine I can't even
write tuning so on the second one you'd
have something like the task you're
actually interested in and let's say the
task you're actually interested in is
sentiment classification so in sentiment
classification you have like a sentence
like blah blah blah and you want to know
is that a positive sentiment like is a
happy sentence or is it a sad sentence
and you would have a database of labeled
instances of that so in this database
you'd have a bunch of sentences and for
each one you would know is it good is it
is it positive or is it negative and
then you'd have like a smaller test set
right here and you would you would train
you would basically take this pre
trained model train it on this dataset
in a supervised machine learning way and
then test it on this test set right here
this is called fine tuning that's what
they display here so in fine tuning the
model is trained via repeated gradient
updates using a large corpus of example
tasks
right so the example task right here
could be translating to French so in
your training database of the
translation task would be this would be
C order is called Lu treadmill and in
and and then you'd actually change your
model you'd do a gradient update I mean
if if you're in the NLP world this seems
very natural but they are going to argue
in a second that this isn't the only way
that you can teach a model a task right
so this this seems very natural right
you don't change your model you take
your pre trained model and you're going
to fine-tune it on this task and if you
have a different task right if you have
now question answering tasks you're
going to have a different data set right
here with a train and test data set and
you're going to take the pre trained
model and then fine-tune it on that data
set and evaluate it on that test set so
this gives you basically with as many
models as you have tasks Andy for each
one you need a big big training data set
in order to perform well sometimes we
have this sometimes we don't what they
are interested in is basically to take
the pre trained model and directly go
and evaluate it on the test data set in
a sort of a zero shot fashion now it is
not zero shot as they will argue so what
are they doing in a true zero shot
fashion you would just take your your
language model that you pre trained and
you just input the following text you
input what they call a task description
and a prompt so this is the input and
you were simply asked the model as a
language model to predict the next word
it's just what comes here now what
you're counting on is basically that in
the training data the model has seen a
structure like this enough to understand
what's going on
so that in the training data somewhere
in the internet there was the structure
of translate something to something and
then there would be a word here of
something and you know it kind of has to
realize that this goes here like
the next word so basically what you're
asking it is if you were to find this
text on a website or on Wikipedia or in
any of the books data set if you were to
find this piece of text what would be
the next word in that piece of text and
you kind of hope that this this is
enough if you've trained a good language
model that this is enough to to to
actually produce the French translation
here now before I realize I've said the
language modeling is to teach the model
the English language actually not true
in this common crawl corpus you also
have many foreign languages so you
basically teach you the general model of
the internet now they translate they
contrast this to what they call one-shot
learning so in one-shot learning you not
only do you have the task description
right here and this is this is a string
right you don't specifically tell the
model that this is now a translation
task you simply input this as a string
so not only do you have the task
description and the prompt right here
but you also have one example and the
example and this is where they this is
where they bring in the where they say
it's not exactly zero shot where's my
little drawing here so the example is
going to come from the training data set
of the task that you're interested in
but the important part is you never
train on it
you never explicitly train on that
example you simply put it in the context
so you simply put this string so
translate English to French newline C
order lute is Lu to the mere newline
cheese is what you simply input that
string into the model as a language
model and you ask it what's the next
word right here okay so I hope I hope
this is clear this is what they call
kind of one-shot generalization and by
one-shot they basically mean you simply
provide this thing in the
texts of the model as a language model
now the the advantage here is
immediately clear that you only have to
train one model then and then basically
at inference time you can just input the
task description and the sort of
training data for the task into its its
evaluation context and the task itself
and it will if if it is if it really
does what they claim it does it would be
able to sort of understand the prompt
here understand what it means to
translate from English to French it
would look at this example and say oh
that's what you want me to do okay and
then it would be able to generalize to
this input right here to say ah okay
from the task description and the
example I saw I get I get what you want
me to do I will the next word here is
cheese what's cheese in French I don't
remember homage homage now the way the
language model is going to interpret
that is slightly different as we said
before the way the language model is
going to interpret is if you were to
find the following text on a website
somewhere the text is called translate
English to French new line C order goes
to Luton a new line cheese goes to what
would be the next word on that website
so that's what the model sees right you
have to differentiate between what the
human wants and what the model sees the
model is just a language model that is
going to take the next that it's just
going to determine if I were to see this
text somewhere what will be the most
likely next word so you have to phrase
your tasks in a way that makes sense in
that thing and they also have this few
short thing where you not only provide
one context but you provide a bunch of
context to basically tell the model more
of what it what it should do now this
doesn't only work in a free mode where
you basically say what's the next word
here what you can also do if you have
such a language hold with the exact same
model you can give it basically a
a couple of possibilities so you can
give it it's you can say like it's
either shop or its format or its hotel I
think that has like this so you can you
can basically restrict it to only
produce one of these three things
so in translation it might not be you
know the way to go but in if you have
like yes/no answers questions you can
restrict it to that so in a lot of these
NLP tasks you have some options given
for a given question and you can also
restrict it so don't you know you always
have to go with the task at hand but
this is in essence what the model does
and this is I think this is the new well
not the new per se but this is one of
the core ideas of this paper if you take
anything from it there's no new
architecture right here there's no new
wisdom in training they train in a
standard way in a standard language
modeling fashion a standard transformer
architecture this just happens to be
ginormous okay this right here this
thing where they say most of these
things would fine tune and then
basically end up with one model per task
and you need a big data set per task but
we simply can do this since we have such
a large language model it is basically
already basically already knows how to
do this tasks as long as we formulate
them in a language model way we can have
the model perform these tasks and they
will show that this works surprisingly
well throughout this paper now we get
into the experimental results right here
and the experimental results first of
all on language modeling as you can see
here they basically say as you go up
with the parameters you see the Moriya
ones are the parameters you go into your
validation loss goes down and down and
down and down and I believe this is sort
of a log scale as well so this is the
log probability so the the perplexity
and that the this basically follows a
trend
this is a log scale this this is a log
scale it follows a trend where as you
scale up the model and as you scale up
the compute that the model gets and we
know for these big language models we
basically know you have to scale up
model size compute time and dataset size
in the same fashion for them to make
these gains but if you do that it
follows like a a power law where as you
scale up these things the model
basically gets better and better and
better and the question of course is you
know how far how far can we go with this
but for now it seems to hold quite well
that you can just make improvements by
scaling up your model on language
modeling at least so where do we where
do we basically go from here so before
we dive into the actual results of the
individual task so now they're going to
formulate these individual tasks so they
have like pure language modeling tasks
right here like Alice was friends with
Bob Alice went to visit her friend and
then it's like what's the next word okay
it's Bob and George bought some baseball
equipment a ball a glove and a what's
the next word and I guess this should be
hat that's re bat right here but we're
going to go into the into the tasks and
one of them is for example question
answering
so in question answering you simply get
either you get just a pure question or a
context and a question and they do the
fact that they test where a situation
where you just get the question so you
just get I don't know who is the Queen
of England or something like this and
the model is simply to produce either
the results direct or to choose from a
bunch of answers which one is the most
likely as a language model and as you
can see as you scale up the language
model the zero shot one shot and few
shot predictions so in few shot you give
64 different examples from the training
set in the context so you always have so
your context is going to look something
like this and they have examples at the
bottom and I haven't looked at the QA
task but the the example is going to be
something like this you have a task
description like answer the following
questions answer the question and then
you have your example so in zero shot
that's zero and one shot it's one that's
what I like and then you say how tall
who sorry who I don't know who climbed
Everest the first the rest the first and
then you say Hillary I think it was
Hillary no I don't remember and then you
say I don't know how how tall is the
Empire State Building and then you have
like some number here and at the end you
say what was was it was a question from
before I don't know who is the queen of
England yeah who is the queen of England
and then you ask the model to predict
the next word right here okay and you do
this in a closed book setting which
means you have no access to Wikipedia or
whatever like usually these systems they
can go and query Wikipedia but this
system doesn't so you just you just want
to know what has the model learned about
the world by simply absorbing giant
amounts of text so if somewhere in the
training data the fact that the Queen of
England is Elizabeth the second is
present it should complete this right
here and it performs surprisingly well
as you can see here so it manages to
outperform a fine-tuned state-of-the-art
model that is that is fine-tuned on
question answering right this has it has
been built for question answering and
this model outperforms it by simply
having a lot of of language so this here
is the results on on these open domain
QA tasks and you you see right here
it ad this this few shot it outperforms
this open domain that open domain means
that the model can go and look at some
Wikipedia page and yeah so so this is
pretty cool but there are other things
like the natural questions where it
under performs compared to this open
domain thing and they say this is mainly
due to the natural questions being like
it's very much about factual Wikipedia
knowledge and so on maybe like the
question we just made maybe is more of a
natural question type of thing and since
and the model is apparently not as good
at that but it's still impressive that
the model is able to do this out of the
box okay so before I said something like
before we go into the experiments I want
the following so I have like some sort
of hypothesis it's not it's an it's not
an uncommon hypothesis that basically
these things these giant language models
right they they're just these
transformers layer after layer after
layer with their connections in here
what I think is happening is they are
simply storing the training data right
they're simply storing the training data
in these connections right here
so usually you think of storing the
training data in some form of maybe we
have like some module right here some
database module in the neural network
and it learns to query the module but
ultimately if you train a neural network
what you have is data and you train a
function with parameters on that data
and ultimately what you're doing is
you're distilling the data into these
parameters and you you kind of hope to
learn some regularities from it but
ultimately the information about your
training data influences or determines
your final parameters of your function
now I can imagine that if you have
such a giant neural network with so many
weights like 17
sorry 170 billion weights that you can
pretty efficiently actually store the
training data in that model and when you
ask this model now to do something what
it basically does is what these people
sort of argue is that it has learned
these language tasks has learned to
reason over language and so on what I
think is happening much more is it will
simply go to the training data since it
has stored the entire training data in
its weights and it will sort of pull out
the five to ten 250 training examples
that are most relevant to what you put
in and it was sort of intercalate right
it could go to the training data and it
will pull out a bunch of training
samples that are relevant to the context
you put in right now and then it will
sort of integrate those into the next
word that's going to come out right here
and I think if you look at this paper in
terms of this so you always write you
input a context and the context is split
into a task description and then it is
split into K different examples and then
it is it is it has a prompt sorry the
series is the prompt so the task
description is please translate from
English to French and the K different
things are K different translations and
then the prompt is you know what what
you should do so it's like half of AK a
half of one of these boxes right here so
these boxes are have blah blah blah
turns to blah blah blah and then the
prompt is simply without the deal at the
right side I think what it does is it
will simply take all of this and it will
go to its own training data which it has
stored in its weights and it will filter
the training data and basically take out
the the things that sort of pattern
match sort of greg x match in a fuzzy
way to this context and then it will
kind of interpolate these training
examples in order to come up with the
answer I don't think there
his reasoning happening here and I'm
we're going to if you go through the
paper with this view then you can a lot
of things actually make sense and I
actually I think that we need we need
what we need when think people think of
like explainable machine learning they
often think that if I'm going to input
something like I'm going to input an
image into a classifier da da da da and
it comes out a certain class car I like
the explained ability should be a which
part of this image was it the wheels was
it the the hood which part of the image
which part of the input image is
responsible for making that
determination what I think in especially
in these language models what we should
do is if the model predicts something
right here the next word I think we
should somehow have a method of
determining which of the training
examples that the model used to
interpolate given this context because
I'm pretty sure these training is you
will find so if you'll find that for
example this weight and this weight and
this weight was very responsible for
making this prediction happen I'm pretty
sure you can somehow during training
build an index of which of the which
five training examples had most
influence on that particular weight or
on this combination of weights and then
you can sort of go backwards and say you
made this decision right here model
please tell me which of the training
data samples were responsible for making
that decision actually pretty sure that
already exists like I'm never the first
one to think of these things though if I
am site may like the channel now but
just an interesting way to think about
this model and an interesting way to
think about kind of what does what would
explain ability even mean in a model
like this and my argument is since it
interpolates the training data the
interpretability should come from the
fact of which training samples does it
interpolate okay let's go to Tran
halation so in translation as we said
they simply input the like the task and
then the few examples and then and then
at the output okay and you can see right
here what you can see is that again as
the model goes up in parameters the
performance generally increases and also
you can see that the performance is
pretty good every time that this model
goes to English so it goes if it if the
target language is English which sort of
makes sense because like a large part of
the corpus they trained on is English so
being an English language model it
should be pretty good if it is asked to
produce English and it's not as good if
it is asked to go into a different
direction now what you also see is that
it is not really a difference whether
you translate from from which language
you translate but if you go to English
but it very much matters to which
language you go if it is from English so
this sort of makes sense in that it is
just trained on a lot of English data
and right here sometimes they are on par
with the with the state-of-the-art
supervised methods and also other times
they outperform these methods right here
and these methods are unsupervised but
are specifically so they don't have a
supervised training data set that goes
let's say from English to French but
they are built with this in mind that
they need to translate later so they are
sort of task specific but don't have a
supervised training set and this model
right here it just learns whatever it
learns and it it just it just does it
just does this this language model
learning and at the end just because it
has seen some websites where language of
both things appear it can now translate
reasonably well okay now
yeah so the results here are a bit noisy
but it is still interesting to see that
it sometimes even gets close to the
supervised thing though they say that
they are not familiar with the
literature and are not sure that these
model that these numbers are you know
good okay okay the next thing is these
um Winograd schemes where you do have
where is the text here is a classic NLP
task that involves determining which
word a pronoun refers to when the
pronoun is grammatically ambiguous but
semantically unambiguous to a human so
these are sort of human produced
sentences where it's kind of program
could refer to multiple things
I don't have a example present but where
do we have the right here you can see
that this model will out produce a
fine-tuned Bert large but will not out
produce a fine-tuned roberta large so it
is going to it is going to come it is
competing at least with the fine-tuned
models that were made specifically for
that task right again this is pretty
pretty interesting and you also see that
the larger models here it starts to make
a difference whether or not you give it
one zero or one or more examples okay so
we'll get into we'll get into the more
interesting things right here in this
thing right here where is it yes this is
the kind of a physical physical question
physical QA where it is a bit of common
sense reasoning so you're asked to I
don't
yeah these are like science questions
multiple choice questions collected from
a third to ninth grade exams and the
physical QA is physical QA asks
common-sense question about how the
physical word work world works and is
intended as a probe of grounded
understanding of the world
so it has questions as I understand it
it has questions like if a drop a ball
will it fall on the ground or where will
it fall or something like this and they
say that they can outperform a
fine-tuned state-of-the-art model on
this if they go just high enough and you
can also see that there isn't much of a
difference between zero one and few
short the methods of this model right
here
even those zero shot is even higher than
one shot so this is probably just noise
but then you find out that they have an
asterisks here and this means that this
this is potentially a contaminated data
set so they have potential contamination
issues so what they found was there was
a significant overlap between the data
set this data set and their training
data set and they even they only
realized this too late because there was
a bug in their deduplication code and
then they couldn't change it anymore
like I because this model is so large
that they couldn't restart the training
because they've already spent like so
much money and energy on it and this is
crazy I think these language models are
getting so large that we should building
them
we should more think of it like we built
the the International Space Station or
something like this where it's a project
where humanity sort of collaborates or
there's a big effort and you build it
once and whatever you have you have
right so these these good numbers here
are simply or not simply or
because or could be influenced by this
contamination and I think that's what's
happening right here even though they
will make the case that this
contamination isn't really an issue I
can probably show you that it may be it
may be actually is an issue because on
the other data sets at the the
fine-tuned state-of-the-art model
outperform the GPT three quite a bit so
and also the the fact that the you know
if you provide a demonstration or many
demonstrations it doesn't actually
change that much it kind of tells me
that the model sort of already knows
what the answer is and doesn't really
need demonstrations because it doesn't
help if you have the training data
stored or the the test data you don't
really have to get demonstrations right
so they have a few other a few other
things right here we're on this cocoa
tasks they perform pretty poorly
compared to others or poorly let's say
they perform well but not particularly
more well than a state of the art and
they perform especially poorly on the
reading comprehension sorry that's the
that's the cocoa so in reading
comprehension what you have to do is
abstractive multiple choice and span
based answer formats in both dialogue
and single question settings so
basically if you read a piece of text
like this and then answer a question
about the piece of text now this is
something where I think you cannot
really interpolate the training data
super well and therefore so you can't
really just pattern match and interpret
because you have to do actual reasoning
and I think that's why the model
performs poorly here they do measure
this on on super glue which is a NLP
benchmark and
also here you can see it doesn't
outperform a fine-tuned state-of-the-art
model on these tasks but it does
outperform a fine-tuned berthed model
slightly the word model is fine-tuned on
these things whereas gt3 isn't but
notice the tasks in which it does well
and in which it doesn't do well compared
to the state-of-the-art model so for
example in the book you it doesn't do
particularly well right the state of
your is 91 it only has 76 that's quite a
large difference and actually have the
glue benchmark open here and you can see
this is the bull queue so an example
here would be is France the same time
zone as the UK and then there is like a
passage and you need to reason about
from this passage about whether or not
this answer is true or false
okay this this is very much not language
modeling this is reasoning and that's
why the model is doing poorly here
whereas in another thing you see these
for example is Coppa right here the
model is doing almost as good as a
fine-tuned state of the art and I have
to stress this model has never actually
learned this task in a supervised duay
it's simply a language model and I have
this COPO task right here and these are
the examples so one example is the
premise the man broke his toe what was
the cause of this and you have two
different things that it could be either
he got a hole in his sock or he dropped
a hammer on his foot and the way you
phrase it in this model is he would give
the premise as the context and then you
simply ask the model since it's a
language model which of these two things
is more probable to come and of course
it is going to select the thing that can
have happened more often in the training
data and you know broke his toe the
cause of breaking his toe that is the
hammer this is entirely conceivable that
a language
would know this and with enough training
data could sort of pull from the
training data examples where hammer on
foot and broke toe appear a bunch of
times and hole in sock would be rather
unrelated so as long as these questions
are not to adversarial constructed
specifically that a language model can't
solve them there the model is going to
perform pretty well right here right so
it's very interesting to see that if you
view this as interpolating the training
data it's only makes sense where it's
good and where it isn't good so this was
the super glue and and nli it is
performing particularly poorly on nli
which is the ability to understand the
relationship between two sentences right
so where the model classifies whether
the second sentence logically follows
from the first contradicts the first or
is possibly true neutral okay so this is
the reasoning part of this model is not
given
it is simply recalling the training data
and doing language modeling now they say
oh we can test this we can test this
with synthetic and qualitative tasks so
they invent some own task sinks you know
now it's pretty easy since you don't
have to fine-tune the model you don't
have to turn to generate an actual
training set for it tasks so you can
focus on generating a test set and and
you know that's what they do so they do
something like arithmetic so they say
okay can we come up with a bunch of
arithmetic tasks for example two digit
digit addition so what the model would
see would that this is an example and
what the model would see is simply this
as a context right here for the prompt
and if you give it examples so if this
is like one-shot learning you would
input add the following numbers
the following numbers as a string right
then a new line and then you would give
it one example like what is 11 plus 12
and with the answer together with the
answer answer is I don't know 23 and
then you the prompt goes here so what is
48 plus 76 and then you ask what is the
next word right here what is the next
string tok and the comes here now the
the inference here is that if the model
manages to do this it can't simply
because these are all strings the model
basically has no clue how to do math
these are numbers to the model these are
just tokens or strings and the inference
is if the model can do this it must have
learned you know some kind of reasoning
ability it must have learned to like
perform some logic inside so they go
into two-digit addition three digit
addition four digit addition five digit
addition and even multiplication and
subtraction and the results are right
here so as you can see the lower
parameter models they perform pretty
poorly but as you go up the parameters
the big model is performing really well
in the two-digit range is performing
also really well so accuracy of look
that accuracy 8090 percent in three
digit addition and subtraction but then
if as soon as you get into the four
digit or the two digit multiplication
and so on the performance drops now they
say that's because multiplication is
harder and if you know it is logically
very computationally you know but the
two digit addition and so on model has
learned something about the world I
disagree because so here's the because
what you will do is you will simply and
this you simply recall the training data
so look at the two digit addition with
zero shot you already get seventies
% but with one shot you get 99% and with
few shot you get a hundred percent so if
you interpret this model is simply
filtering the training data to pattern
match then it makes a lot of sense that
the one shot would like the examples
here will give you a much improvement
because if you have a bunch of examples
where please add right at and then oh I
erased our example again so you have
like 48 plus 72 equals blah blah blah
you have these of this if you give more
and more example all of a sudden this
looks like a table and they say we made
sure that the strings here these
particular strings were not in our
training data right so these strings
never appeared but I just have an issue
with this deduplication stuff because
what can appear actually is not the what
can appear is a table and in table often
you have columns and then another column
will be the some of these columns on the
left and if you are asked to pattern
match you'll naturally find websites
right if you have a few of these
examples you'll find websites where the
columns exactly refer to these things
and then you'll find the sum here and if
you filter for websites that appear to
match your scheme in the examples you
will find all the website with a table
on them where the the column 1 column is
an addition of the others and I can
actually do that so I went and I typed
in just a bunch of these things so 98
plus 45 is 143 18 plus 55 is 70 I
believe at least and I can find now
Google makes it hard because they
localize and everything but you can
still find what you're going to find our
tables and tables and tables and tables
and now I actually went to dr. go to
basically say
you know they they don't you know really
personalize it to me and what's the
first thing I find when I type in just
these numbers is math skip counting
missing sequence number and a website
where basically the answers are already
given look at that so all the model has
to do is recall this particular training
example from the samples it already has
right and it will it will basically be
able in quotes to perform addition like
this is financial data and another one
where you have to subtract stuff right
so I'm pretty sure all the model is
doing here is interpolating the training
data and that's also why it performs
worse if if you up the digits because
longer digit numbers are simply less
frequent in the in in the training data
multiplication is first of all less
frequent and second of all it also
results in larger numbers which are less
frequent right so it explains a lot so I
yeah I have my issues with people saying
yeah this this shows some reasoning I
don't think it does the same thing here
with word scramble so in word scramble
they have different things you see okay
they they they look whether or not only
17 matches 0.8% of the math things are
in their training data is like no you
haven't searched well enough and the
rest of their deduplication by the way
is also pretty weak I would say because
they just look for like 13 gram overlaps
between the training data and the inde
and their their test data so they have
these words scrambling tasks where they
basically scramble words and they asked
the model to unscramble it for example
this word is inevitably scrambled so
they always you know they give like
anagrams and they give random insertion
into the world like this word right here
or they reverse the word
and they say so this I think this is the
thing at the very beginning but if you
can see right here also as the model
goes up then this this improves and they
also say well this means maybe some kind
of reasoning but I think this is just
it's learning the language and it's
learning that you know the the words in
in sorry that the letters make up a word
and the letters correspond to word
pieces Laura are associated with word
pieces and it always learns to English a
good tasks to check this would actually
be to scramble words so if you
unscramble words you always end up with
an English word
so all it has to do is basically check
which word has the highest overlap in
word pieces but you could do something
like please scramble this word and then
always count it correctly when any of
the scrambling of the words so instead
of going from this to this which you can
simply solve by knowing the English
language but you would have basically no
clue what the task is that you don't
have to understand that as a model you
could ask it to go from this to this
given a few examples right then it would
really need to understand what the task
is that it's supposed to actually
scramble a word and would would need to
learn that from its context given
examples but they as far as I see they
don't do that and again I think it's
recalling the the training data the this
is Sat analogies so the SAT or this test
that in the US high schoolers take to
get into college and the this if they
say a typical example this is dying on
me now it scrolled okay a typical
example is the following this I find I
find pretty hilarious audacious is to
boldness as sanctimonious is to
hypocrisy anonymous is to identity
remorseful still missed
deleterious is to result or
impressionable is to temptation this is
a as as a okay I'm not a native speaker
but this is a hard question right and
you have to you know see that these
these high-schoolers they're stressed
like this is very much a time-based test
so you need to make a decision quickly
well the model of course is basically
able to sift through its entire training
data in the time it takes to GPUs to
perform inference but it's still funny
that gt3 achieves fifty sixty five
percent in the few shots setting and
fifty-nine percent in one shot setting
fifty three percent is zero short
setting whereas the average score among
college applicants was fifty seven
percent so it outperforms the average
college applicant it's pretty funny but
you would expect the language model to
have a pretty good grasp of these kind
of synonyms and relations between words
because these are just absolutely
statistical associations between words
so yeah this I found this to be pretty
pretty funny and the last thing and this
is what everyone's freaking out over is
this news article generation where
basically they give it the beginning of
a few of a news article and then they
let humans decide whether or not the
news article is written by a machine or
by a human and they say here by contrast
mean human accuracy at detecting
articles that were produced by the one
hundred seventy five billion parameter
model it was barely above chance at
fifty two percent human abilities to
detect model generated text appear to
decrease as model size increases there
appears to be a trend towards chance
accuracy with model size and human
detection of g PT three is close to
chance okay
so what they do is they give indeed they
have some examples right here
they give the model the following input
the title the subtitle of an article and
then this word article the model is
supposed to complete
the rest of the article right here and
you can also you know give do this in a
few shots setting such that the model
basically knows that it's if you give it
a few a few examples the model knows it
is supposed to produce a news article
right okay so there are two two ways
that you can think of this first way the
model has learned the language so well
and it writes code it has learned to
write coherent language and so on is
learn to reason keep context and blah
blah blah okay
second way the model sees this thing
right here it sees the few you know K
few shot examples that it has before in
the context it will take them filter the
training data to in this case it just
sees news articles so do just news
articles it will take this thing filter
the training data even more to just the
news articles that pertain largely to
topics or words that appear in here and
then lastly will interpolate the few
training examples to produce this thing
now they argue that this isn't really
possible because they have actually
checked that this news article is not in
the training data but I have simply gone
and taken a you I've really taken a
random substring here I've taken this
substring voted to strengthen a ban on
the ordination of just this substring
and I've put it into Google and Bob Reba
I find a book with voted to strengthen
prohibitions to ban LGBTQ people from
being ordained and ministers so it's you
know I find this it's not the same
article but it's talking about the same
incident the article talks about and it
is using the same language probably read
the article and the author is like I
can't really you know copy paste that
would be you know not really cool so
I'll just kind of you know write it in
my own words but largely the same thing
The Associated Press here also a
different article you know see
title than this one right here but about
the same thing and also with the same
language right here voted Tuesday to
strengthen the faiths divisive bans on
same-sex marriage and ordination of LGBT
clergy and generally so the argument
this article wasn't in the training data
is just not really something I buy in
this in this case so I think it the
article as such wasn't there but many
articles about this topics were and I
think this will just interpolate these
now they say this was the hardest
article for the humans to decide and
this here was the easiest so it's it
says I don't know star talks promise
draws Megyn Kelly's sarcasm and says a
year ago joke in Phoenix made headlines
when he appeared on the red carpet at
Golden Globes wearing a tuxedo with a
paper bag over his head that read I'm a
shapeshifter above you you would guess
that joke in Phoenix would do something
like this but they say they're human
raiders were US based right and you see
right here it says men Kelly was not
impressed and she let him have it on The
Tonight Show
another Tonight Show is not when megyn
kelly is and us-based people would I
guess know something like this and would
immediately feel like this is wrong so I
think this thing is interpolated from is
interpolated from a bunch of different
news articles about this and the
interpolation just let it like made it
teach that this person is on this show
which that they aren't and the humans
noticed right well it doesn't change the
fact that it probably just went to the
training data filtered a bunch of
articles about these words and then
interpolated like mash them together it
is a good language model right it can
grammar it's very good at grammar so we
can interpolate different passages of
text and I feel that the the really
really useful application of this will
be sort of as a search engine as a fuzzy
search engine so now
can like input for example my my machine
learning research ideas and what will
output will be sort of an abstract of a
paper that is kind of a merge together
of other papers on the same thing and
that that you know you can think of many
applications I don't think we have built
something really intelligent here and
what this is this is though is pretty
cool
they they give examples like this here
where they make up a world and then ask
the model to use the word in a sentence
so to skree is something sorry to
screech something is to swing a sword at
it an example of a sentence that uses
the word scree is and of course the
model what's the models going to do is
it's going to take this it's going to
filter the training data for all of the
instances we're sort of this
construction appears like an example of
using the word which is mostly so
dictionaries then it's going to not know
that word but it can interpolate from
interpolate it from all this data right
here and the cool thing is it actually
conjugates the where we screed at each
other for several minutes and then we
went outside and ate ice cream so you
can see how this comes to be but I think
it would really be fun to have a model
that tells us which training data
samples were used here it can also
correct English grammar which is pretty
obvious though again it can never
correct so the the input always here is
poor English good English poor English
good image poor good poor English and
then good English and that's what the
model is asked to to output and I'm
actually not sure pretty sure this here
shouldn't be bold I'm fairly sure this
shouldn't be bold this is given to the
model the model is only asked to produce
this otherwise I'd be I'd be actually
impressed but yes
nothing task-specific is provided aside
from the examples from few example as
conditioning and
poor English input good English output
framing so the good English output thing
here should not be in boldface authors
if you're listening this should not be
bold thank you okay but again it is
always as you can see it's too good
English it's always the target is good
English whereas if the model really
understood the task it should also be
able to do the inverse it should be able
to to produce something poor from
something good because then you
eliminate the fact that it's just a good
English language model right because it
can basically produce something like
this without having a clue what the task
is it will simply you condition on this
input and it will simply output this
sentence because it's very likely
because it's already here almost here
and it will output it in better English
because it's a good language model right
it's it's a good English language model
so yeah that so they measure this
overfitting the degree to which they're
training to which their test data is in
this common crawl thing and they say
they have a conservative bound on how
many percent of the data in the data set
are clean and as you can see here they
measure then how much the performance
differs to - up or down if you only
evaluate on the clean portion of this
data set but again their deduplication
is so weak they do like Engram
deduplication whereas I think you should
really like in the news articles you
should really do much more fuzzy
deduplication much more of a meaning
deduplication if you then want to argue
that the model has learned to reason
like if you simply want to argue that
the model is a good language model fine
right but yeah and also look at this
like I would expect of a dataset a test
dataset if you know if you have like a
natural questions dataset it is
constructed from Wikipedia pages and you
have the Wikipedia page in there you can
either either the entire thing is clean
or none of it is clean and also these
Winograd dataset if this dataset somehow
leaked into the common crawl corpus
either the entire thing is clean or none
of it is clean I just have kind of
problems with the fact that there are so
many in-between things right here and
yeah so I'm not I'm not convinced here
that this deduplication I still think
it's a cool thing but I don't I think
it's mostly a training data filter and
interpolator rather than actual
reasoning and they go through some of
the limitations here and the broader in
this broader impact statements like five
pages long and yeah okay you can do you
can you know bad people take the model
to do bad things okay and that's pretty
much it so what I appreciate here is at
the bottom they have basically all the
results but also a lot of tasks
descriptions like how they framed each
tasks or outputs and they gave more
outputs on their website rightly so you
can see here how each of the tasks was
framed where you always have this is
what this here is what the model sees
and then this is what it's asked to
produce right so you have this for for
all many of these things and so on squad
you have this context and the question
okay so the the context is actually in
there I've didn't know that but you have
the context and the question and the
model is asked to complete something
right here so you can look at how the
model sees tasks and maybe you can
evaluate for yourself how you think how
difficult you think these tasks or
alright I hope this was informative it
is a long paper therefore it is a long
video if you're still here and haven't
subscribed yet maybe if you like this if
you want more de leave it a like tell me
in the comments what you think of it
whether you think it's actually
IGI or not and I'll see you next time
bye-bye